[Musique]
deux heures d'autobus si ce que font
tous les jours quand mené candoni ça
pour aller et revenir de l'école c'est
long mais c'est un moindre sacrifice
pour avoir accès à l'éducation qualité
et à peine 60 ans c'est la couleur de
leur peau qui aurait déterminé le sort
de la famille seni je me déteste et
challenges because un big rase des
histoires ou encore white profond comme
d'autres afro américains ils ont intégré
une école dans un quartier mieux nantis
et plus blanc que le leur une école
magnets comme on les appelle ici
créé au nom de la déségrégation dans le
sud des états unis
et si on essayait d'y remonter à moscou
[Musique]
leurs parents ne rate jamais l'occasion
de leur rappeler la bataille qui a été
menée pour que puisse exploiter tout
leur talent parmi les héros qui habite
la bibliothèque du salon la petite
bobine budget est sans doute la plus
inspirante
[Musique]
c'était la première noire qui a mis les
pieds dans une école primaire réservée
aux bus ou bee gees n'avait que 6 ans
lorsqu'elle a monté les marches de
l'école william prince à la nouvelle
orléans
en 1960 on part en blanc déchaînés ont
manifesté pendant des mois ils ont même
menacé devant elle a passé toute sa
première année dans une classe vide avec
une institutrice venue de boston
parce que personne dans ce ne voulait
lui enseigner
cette scène dub oubli qui va à l'école
protégée par des agents fédéraux a été
rendu célèbre par le père noël et a
marqué l'imaginaire de millions
d'américains barack obama est devenu
président c'est une des premières toiles
qu'il a emprunté pour la maison blanche
aujourd'hui rouby bridge il reçoit un
autre hommage pour sa contribution au
mouvement des droits civiques à 64 ans
elle se rappelle de tout et dégage la
même force tranquille estime jeff heart
cheap show me your heart inside line
chine stephen son école et
éventuellement devenu un modèle
d'intégration dans le sud n'est pas pour
longtemps
quand elle lui a remis les pieds au
début des années 2000 pour inscrire ses
neveux le choc a été brutal
sophos
ce qui est arrivé à l'école de moby
c'est ce qui arrive dans la majorité des
écoles urbaines du sud les blancs sont
partis
l'ania jones une militante nous fait
visiter quartier où elle a grandi dans
les années 80 l'exode des blancs s'est
fait lentement
bâton rouge est aujourd'hui une des
villes les plus divisé des états unis
nous sommes sur le boulevard ford a on
l'appelle ici la frontière entre noirs
et blancs
le sud et prospère le nord des noirs et
pauvres
les écoles ont été les grandes victimes
de cette ségrégation résidentielle
le taux d'échec est alarmant
[Musique]
le faut si raciale économique se creuse
d'année en année ici loin d'être
terminée aujourd'hui des parents comme
moi et n'aurait ni se bat pour former
leurs propres zones scolaires
une pratique répandue aux états unis qui
sous le couvert de la réussite ferme la
porte aux enfants des quartiers pauvres
majoritairement à froid mik
en 2018 plus de 60 ans après l'abolition
officielle de la ségrégation dans les
écoles la question ce pot chaud et oies
point barre
[Musique]
des enfants comme quand des lycées et
collèges qui avance à contre courant
dans cette société où le racisme est
ancrée et le progrès toujours fragile
aux eaux
[Musique]